[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui bonsoir chancel au quatrième étage
m'en souviens très bien merci je change
[Musique]
e
quand j'ai fait mon premier livre en 72
c'est le premier journaliste qui m'a
reçu pour en parler ouais ouais
radioscopie
lui demander pourquoi il m'a reçue en
fait j'ai jamais demandé
30 30 et quelques années plus tard c'est
du champagne jean
je vais jouer
[Musique]
comment tu veux attirer ça va très très
bien mais votons appartement j'écoute
mes tendons de ceux-là d'accord ça va
ajuster très belles chambres du pouget
le coup là
c'est pas un lit pour dormir servi pour
coucher en fait c'est vrai que ça fait
lit de sa luge yves jacques chancel
trouve que ça fait un peu l'idée a
séduit monde annoncé un lead si les bras
on est bien c'est un livre luxueux et un
lit de luxure absolument je viens on va
boire un coup
le salaire grandiose c'est grand il ya
surtout non il ya surtout une chose ici
qui m'avait jacques chancel eric fréchon
comment ça va changer
aussi alors les bonnes lorsqu'ils ont
essayé ça se prépare tout doucement
il caffè un menu spécial pour toi dakar
gens alors je ne donne rien 6 il suffit
alors qu'est ce qu'il ya ce qu'il a fait
un bouquin à gonzague saint-bris wind
champagne sur l'éducation gourmande de
flaubert on a fait une recherche sur
tout ce qu'il avait pu manger à travers
de sa vie et puis moi gérard et adapter
un petit peu il était vraiment gourmets
ouais c'était un gourmet gourmand ouais
ouais ouais ouais vraiment et puis bon
il est né enfin les normands tout ce qui
était crustacés
byrne post vous n'auriez que la
madeleine ou des
écoutes alors j'ai avant avant que tu as
je disais à eric que
tu m'avais reçu pour mon premier livre
cinémoi ouais mais pourquoi tu m'avais
reçus parce que j'avais reçue pour ton
bouquin ouais bah là dessus et pourquoi
tu me reçoit un mec comme moi mais parce
que d'abord sonné reconnaissez j'allais
le sujet était intéressant j'avais 23
ans sujet était intéressant c'était bien
écrit d'ailleurs c'est la paresse qui
t'a fait mener la victime c'est vrai
lorsque ce qui est excellent et tu fais
beaucoup de choses aux goûts de luxe et
à la vérité tu ne fais plus rien de ce
que tu devrais faire vous devrez écrire
et la libye c'est de faire de la radio
de la télévision pour ne pas écrire
quelque chose dans le droit d'en
terminer un roman ah oui j'ai écrit une
quarantaine de livres mais j'attendais
j'attendais je faisais des tas d'autres
livres pour ne pas écrire se rendre je
connais donc l'histoire je fais autre
chose pour ne pas faire ce pour quoi
peut-être en effet non moi c'est vrai
que quand j'ai vu comment vivaient les
écrivains je me suis dit est ce que j'ai
envie de cette vie d'à quoi est ce que
j'ai envie d'être là d'attendre le
papier de machin enveloppe le papier de
choses dedans non france soir est ce que
j'ai envie d'attendre d'avoir le bon
coup pour m'acheter un appartement à
comprendre le concorde et pourquoi mais
la question n'est pas là es tu content
d'être ce que tu es devenu oui oui parce
que j'ai quand même écrit 5,6 bouquin
quand même et puis parce que j'ai quand
même je pense qu'avant d'écrire il faut
vivre et que ce que j'ai vécu depuis 20
ans quand même extraordinaire et puis on
n'y peut rien si c'est du grès de ligue
2 un kit eu voilà donc à partir de ce
moment ça va moi je n'en suis pas
frustré si c'est ce que tu veux dire je
suis pas super frustré de pas écrire
plus puis j'ai le temps et pas forcèment
était toujours inquiet oui c'est à dire
que c'est vrai que ça n'aurait plus de
faire ça j'ai pas eu le courage qu'a eue
beigbeder et j'ai pas eu les ventes
qu'il a eu c'est à dire que quand tu
vends deux ou trois cent mille
exemplaires d'un bouquin ça te rassure
si tu veux moi j'en ai pas vendu ça au
début un il est parti à 99 valeur
justement parce que à l'époque où toi tu
m'a reçue déjà fallait recevoir d'ici là
bon ça durait une heure c'était
personnes donc déjà une heure tu m'avais
accordé une heure au sein de terre et
aujourd'hui qui fait ça je réfléchissais
à sa qui reçoit tous les écrits marie à
poivre d'arvor bizarrement oui c'est
pendant son émission littéraire il
s'oblige à recevoir les écrivains qui
sont pas des stars qui sont pas des
auteurs de best-sellers il donne un peu
la parole comme ça la corde des
écrivains qui fait ça aujourd'hui toi tu
le fais sur france inter et encore c'est
tous les dimanches mais je vois lorsque
j'avais commencé radioscopie mais la
première semaine
il fallait quand même assuré un peu
l'avenir de ces techniques fayolle alors
j'avais choisi le premier c'était roger
vadim
le deuxième c'était
romain gary et le troisième c'était
jorge luis borgès ça va oui donc j'avais
que l'allosaure ges ah ouais c'est chez
nord et après j'ai fait une semaine
entière avec borgès vénère j'avais fait
aussi et une semaine entière avec albert
cohen à genève c'est une semaine entière
avec marguerite yourcenar à mon désert
dans les temps non parce que j'ai dû
faire un peu près 25 fois une semaine
parce que une heure ça n'était pas assez
dit moi alors l'indochine terre n'a
jamais parlé en fait non c'est amusant
ce que tu me dis parce que un soir nous
étions aux agneaux et dîner et j'ai bien
les pierre chalard faits ont eu lieu
mais une douzaine de personnes à table
puis un certain moment quelqu'un est de
me raconter lyon un peu ce que vous avez
vécu là ouais non on s'est mis à
raconter mais des histoires on verra on
n'a pas pris le côté négatif de la
guerre qui est effroyable n'en ai pas on
n'allait pas parler de nos souffrances
je vais parler de la rue catinat parler
de tout et il y avait bernard fixot il
faut que tu écrives sas qui pourrait
m'intéresser parce que j'ai parlé non
mais limogés par les luttes du vietnam
souvent vrai je n'ai pas parlé d'une
manière complète et par bus d autre que
de moi et ce qui me paraît très
important puisque j'étais parti pour le
vietnam au besoin
soit monsieur cdi et carl quatrième
étage il vous plait merci aujourd'hui
j'ai 24 ans
[Musique]
j'ai divisé le coeur
la petite madame
c'est
par la nature leur mandat terminé dans
un bain de sang dans l'imagination mais
ça se passe là bas je suis parti d'un
concept très simple c'est à dire que la
vie le monde dans lequel je suis ne
convient pas du tout je
me fiche identique
plus un
[Musique]
oh
samedi
vous
[Musique]
mon second soir
bonsoir monsieur bonsoir
considérons revêtement
les pépins
thurella diène
c'est qui gît là
elle du monde qui
à l'autre karl
car jouer soit rejoué ce soir à quoi je
vais la roulette rigole non j'adore le
jeu pour moi un miroir noir de caracas à
moscou ça génial c'est carla
[Musique]
bonsoir mais ça va jamais bien tu es
liens
[Musique]
ça va bien
essayez vos jeux
est
ce que j'ai le droit de manger un peu
déphasé si on joue on joue à quoi la
roulette ou à la roulette russe
alors moi je ne juge jamais mais quand
j'ai su que vous avez des numéros
des canons on verra tout à l'heure mais
parce que moi j'ai mes numéros j'ai une
base de numéro je peux le dire
09 23 45 et les chevaux 0 je ne peux que
te féliciter baisser car
d'ailleurs parce que je mets 0 jeudi
karl et les joueurs à la vérité le
ferais joueurs aiment à perdre le vrai
joueur meridia il ya vraiment une
rythmique que tu vois un érotisme du jeu
et le si on se met à jouer comme jouent
certains je reconnais pas vrai par
exemple dans notre univers qui jouent
comme des imbéciles des idiots d'abord
il joue devant tout le monde et c'est
indécent ce qui joue je pourrais citer
un personnage le site phare c'est un
dessin non au pouvoir joue bien et
jouent bien souvent j'en ai qu un
novateur il souffre d'une jambe il joue
intelligemment à chaque fois que je vais
où je
sais pas quand même il peut rejouer
maintenant amener à la table je sais pas
les interdire de la vie à deauville à la
table de stud poker oui pis le blackjack
et c'est la table la plus chère
alouettes à 100 ou 200 euros le jeton
donc c'est beaucoup moi je comprends
rien ça va très très vite lui il assure
très très bien mais enfin il il arrive à
peine à équilibrer dans l'année me dit
il donc en fait c'est juste le plaisir
d'être l'affinage et les toits que j'ai
eu beaucoup de vent beaucoup mais je
joue je joue mais je viens m'installer à
côté de bouvard je tiens une heure est
au bout d'une heure en fonction soit
j'ai trop gagner et elle me prend tout
elle se barre soit j'ai tellement perdu
que j'ai honte et je me casse parce que
j'ai pas les moyens de bouvard cheveux
pour les grosses têtes j'espère bien je
n'aime pas ce que tu veux par mégaphone
n'est pas connu j'ai fait avec louis
ferdinand céline je sais tu as ta vie
mais c'est bien sûr mais mais pas pour
la merci papa du tout pour la radio
forcément pas pour la télévision mais
une série de reportages qui sont passés
d'ailleurs à l'époque dans le premier
journal de division qui s'appelait télé
magazine n'y avait pas d'autres à
l'époque tu n'as interviewé céline ou à
meudon en dehors bien sûr il me dit 0
face le mont valérien tous ces [__]
et il avait c'était formidable montée
jamais propre au premier étage où ou
pratiquer sa femme le sait - eni monte
jamais et ce qui était fabuleux c'est
que dans sa pièce il y avait comme si on
accroche et du linge - et avec ses
pinces à linge était accroché ses
feuilles de papier et pour faire de
phrases c'est une page entière ah oui
c'est vrai il écrivait gros louis donc
c'était un ciel de feuilles de papier
kraft est magnifique avec de temps en
temps les chiens qui rend très léchée
allemand et qui mordille est également
une porte qui est un peu les feuilles
c'est un personnage étrange et une voix
mais une voix un d'une beauté d'un
timbre d'une qualité bon c'est d'abord
c'est un immense écrivain ça c'est sûr
je ne sais pas si on peut oublier ce
qu'il a dit ce qu'il a fait je crois pas
je ne prends pas qu'il ait vendu
beaucoup de joie mais il a eu des
pensées qui ne sont pas conformes voilà
le sol
insistantes
à
oui bonsoir bonsoir c'est juliette et
s'éveille nokia très froid
4e étage chez vous persie
et
monsieur
oui
oh
le début du vrai journal il m'a invitée
dans une émission au tout début avec
bilalian cette émission là c'était ligne
de mire ça on ment pas où l indh
milliard m'en parle encore aux
agriculteurs parce que parce que c'était
un combat de coqs entre
bilalian représentant un peu
journalisme normal extrait mois le
nouveau journalisme le grand journalisme
tu vois ça a été très très violent il y
avait là une affaire
derrière en toile de fond la sphère
tiberi oui je reprochais oppose bilalian
le pont neuf les directeurs des sports
de france 2 membres à savoir la nasa va
très bien même c'était horrible parce
que je lui reprochait d'avoir placé ce
sujet
davenas ce le procureur a envoyé un
hélico chercher chez frankie et oui bon
il a émis sa série en tout bon en 14e
sujet dans son dans son truc soir j'ai
interrompt la conversation
non pas du tout c'était des rendez-vous
sont très bien en soirée vous même jour
mais ce soir c'est la géniale bien jeter
ma foi pour toi comme à mardi
ils d'autre part julien on la comprend
et la pensée humaine seconde édition
avec tous les noms pied les musiciennes
on est les murs ancien gsm et ça se sent
c'est quoi le duo avec guillaume
depardieu à la c'est beau hein c'est
très très beau le bio le duo avec
guillaume ii par ailleurs justement est
pas super facile à dire le duo avec
guillaume depardieu s'est articulé bien
en même temps il faut pas que je le
ferai je suis plus très bien mais que
uniquement quand je chante en fait par
une voisine chantal noms nagy écrit un
petit et voilà j'ai écrit une petite
chanson très très gai ayant pour thème
les amours malheureuses en fait et
l'oubli c'est triste ça fait quoi mon
amour ma bien aimée je reviendrai sois
en sûr comment survivre éloigné de ton
coeur devant le japonais vachement bien
on se connaît pas je cherche le défaut
gens voient pas c'est parce que
justement on connaissait pas ah bon ça
rappelle un film elle a fait le lycée
chimie ou le bouquin qui était surtout
mène ce bouquin tchimou sécheurs ben oui
ça y est ouais et celle connaît toujours
pas d'ailleurs et de l'année ça non on a
on a donné beaucoup d'auteurs parce que
c'est la femme des sorties trio c'est
pas triste et c'est pas qu'il ya une
raison car on n'a jamais sûr on a dit
que c'était christine au rebond suite au
nadi c'est christine et olivier orban
surnom n'a cité puis c'est merveilleux
de pouvoir citer beaucoup de jérôme
hermet c'est ça qui a trait à ce
moment là pour l'histoire dos mais il
sort quand même fini les sorties dont il
sort le 26 janvier mai à marrakech il a
fait du
film à sortir à marrakech pascal et
phrases cette fille peut provoquer un
jlg en moi à choisir entre libérer la
palestine à l'achat je prends la chatte
longue durée c'est bon
on a passé sa maquette est alors quelle
a été leur réaction
l'idée c'était juste ans ont fait monter
ses patrouilles en ville les gens non
mais en fait on est à l'aise
direction tout de suite le tablier sa
mort
soit bonsoir lehbila ni errants clinique
au quatrième étage cessible
225 kg voir ci-après
225 soit possible à la fraude
moi 125
80 personnes
205 passe déjà on dépense un tout petit
peu se marier
[Musique]
ç'aurait dames messieurs bonsoir madame
vous voulez me conseillez vos vêtements
le panonceau
[Musique]
vous
passer à la cuisine si vous voulez
[Musique]
oui
mais ce sont les menacer
franche comté et j'en finis
ça
il alliait s'excuse on est un peu en
retard
cette époque allait mal aussi
en plus c'est sympa leader
celui-là baquet
et tu donnes sur quoi voix sur pas grand
chose justement
g
j'ai un rapport du jour
je quand je regarde par la fenêtre ici
je vais pas donner un besoin de campari
enfin alors mes enfants oui et
alors
d ici
juliette ici jean philippe ici pour lui
sandrine sandrine ici
ça c'est toi tu es là
salir marrakech au but mais quelle ville
une ville géniale ya un érotisme des
couleurs cependant lorsqu'on arrive à
marrakech les gens deviennent fous ta
d'intesa érotisme des couleurs
c'est vrai et les gens qui arrivent là
bas moi j'ai un copain j'ai d'abord
des trucs incroyables
érotisme des couleurs il s'en fout
jacques tu es d'accord qu'à un moment à
trois ans on peut dire ce qu'on veut
soit au pouvoir ou tourner et jouer avec
des couleurs on va au reste parce que
mon copain qui est arrivé là bas il est
unique ouvre là tu prennes la palmeraie
du bourg intérêts formidable 15 hectares
il s'installe la saga scream qui met une
tente caïdale quand même à l'état latent
caïdale un lit à baldaquin
il engage une centaine de jeunes de deux
jeunes entre 18 et 25 ans il leur
apprend le métier et retailler la pierre
taillée le mahb et y construire un
palais insensé qui ne sera jamais
terminé il y avait louette qu'il veut
faire 30 cm de profondeur sur 25 cm ils
ont fait quelque chose qui va 7 mètres
de profondeur et 20 mètres de large et
sur un kilomètre
il fait des salons de musique des salons
de jeux et aux parcours à terminent tous
par des bains douches la romaine le
dingue mais certains comme un fourre
tout cas est un moyen beaucoup de
français là bas
là bas mais je pense jean rené fourtou
c'est formidable parce que c'est des
maisons et un son fils plus qu à lui
révisé un gros sculpteur françois rey et
il a fait de cette maison un musée c'est
à dire que fort tout le laisse faire
donc lui il imagine il fait il crée
c'est formidable ce qu'il a fait par
exemple dans la salle à manger ils tout
d'un coup des singes qui tombent du
plafond mais grandeur nature mais qui
sont remarquables près de la piscine ni
un chameau qui se promène dans dans la
sedan dans les toilettes il ya des zones
qui dégouline
mais c'est formidable quand création et
d'un talent fou il a fait une maison
très très très étroite mais qui montrent
très très très haut c'est à dire que il
a imaginé que les gens pourraient avoir
demain de 2,3 m donc les sièges il faut
monter comme montera sur une échelle et
aidé à table parce que la table est très
au delà tablette à peu près de cet
auteur
comment vous êtes rencontrés çà
rencontrer son ancien entraîneur juste
le nom de pierre berbizier qui nous a
présenté lors d'une inauguration d'une
boîte j'étais seul et
on a plein en fait il n'y avait plus de
petits fours alors il m'a dit je voulais
aller manger au resto avec moi oui tout
de suite comme ça oui j'avais tracé les
rapides c'est un
endroit comme ça y avait un bon et j'ai
déjà fait l élégance et dire ce retour
d'ici
qui était très drôle c'est que ça
faisait à peine cinq minutes qu'on se
connaissait il ya quelqu'un qui est venu
taper sur l'épaule et qui lui a dit au
taf on est vraiment super sympa
et puis moi je dis et puis lui me met le
bras comme ça me dit oui je sais je très
fier et là je ne connaissais pas ça
faisait cinq minutes je me suis dit il
est gonflé lui qu'ahmed février et puis
après ça m'a fait sourire et puis j'ai
trouvé sympa
c'est un des plus grands concertistes
aujourd'hui aux états-unis au japon
d'ailleurs c'est une vedette au japon et
aux etats unis beaucoup plus qu'en
france mais son idée aujourd'hui est
assez extraordinaire alors qu'il a
l'habitude des grandes arcades des plus
grands chefs mais il aimerait porter la
musique dans les endroits les plus
reculés
serge faure s'est tendu moi j'ai des
idées non et il a fait comment s'appelle
d'entre eux double croche double croche
cd rosa dans une chapelle dans un maison
de culture dans une ferme du haut des
pyrénées et devant 200 personnes 300
personnes pas plus en fait
c'est un peu de briser la barrière
sociologique c'est la musique classique
c'est toujours sinon les riches qu'on
dit ça et puis même les salles à soual
sont bien quand il parle des choses
elysées de la salle pleyel le truc comme
ça alors les gens il ya des gens qui
s'imaginent que c'est pas pour eux et la
meilleure façon de leur prouver le
contraire cette année chez eux
précisément puis de jouer dans le côté
de la rue or ici en france et un
patrimoine génial il ya toujours une
église qui traîne un château un petit
truc adorable quoi mettre en valeur un
coup de projecteur vers le mois de
novembre et tout ça et puis on met un
piano un violon et puis et puis le
village vient alors moi j'essaye fait
une association qui essayent de
développer ça c'est pas simple parce
qu'il faut briser des trucs
de nuit
qu'est ce que je faisais à l'opéra 16
vous avez commencé elle donc c'est une
véritable école
vous avez très petit rat
gtv6
messi
a vu grand en plus à l'école de roland
petit s'est formée d'un sac et là je
vous étiez petit rat c'était un 9 10 en
dix ans c'est l'âge à son rallye santé
c'est un jeu
aussi j'ai été repéré par une directrice
de casting sur une plage pour faire mon
premier film
les vanina sauvegarde ou chad reed je
suis corse il ya des vahinés en corse il
ya des vahine en scène
fine ça veut dire alors j'ai appris
qu'on voulait a donné à la naissance ou
vous l'avez en
protéines on m'a appelé comme ça c'est à
dire bienvenue en malgache est en fait
j'ai appris après que ça voulait dire
guère aux russes et combat en hébreu
alors je suis quand même dans la merde
avec bienvenue à la gare et au combat
vous que votre père le père en fait là
l'autre père était encore jeune il a
vécu en
qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient
c'est un métier nawab c'est un métier
n'a voile je sais mobilité au moment où
travaillent en commun administrateurs
n'ont pas appliqué des pierres
précieuses
c'est une question qui ne se pose pas
encore si nous irons puisse poser une
question comme ça mais durant ce quart
je faisais un travail c'est un travail
voilà voilà merten voilà un super g de
mariée non non fillon c'est libre
mais quoi mais je crois que je me suis
seulement curieux vous êtes marrant
moi je n'ose pas la poser parce que tu
veux tu me connais je suis vachement dit
merci le fait que ce soit une chance
celle qui pose des questions à ma place
beau tempérament à oui mais il en faut
pour ce match un beau tempérament dans
la parole le reste je peux pas mais beau
tempérament
c'est de là que deux blocs d'abord on a
créé antenne 2 quand même connu à la
bourgeoise c'est quoi alors qu'elles
peuvent roddick en 8e ce soir maman
fort heureusement des
élites eric vous aimez la queue et ben
je laisse absolument à au château
magique qu'est ce que c'est la queue de
boeuf a que deux femmes amoureuses mais
c'est quoi la queue de boeuf ben queue
de boeuf que dans un pot-au-feu on
récupère les légumes du pot-au-feu que
l'on me rouler dans la côte de boeuf et
on fait ses choux farcis surprise un la
bourgeoise est classé serait derrière
truffes et foie gras oui c'est dur
calcul en temps mais comme un pot-au-feu
tout doucement pendant cinq six ans
masai et moi et moi j'aime à la boucle
est bouclée j'ai le mec du bois est seul
chez
café au bristol et marisol bien chez moi
je vous recommande le brio le bouillant
le bouillant je ne prendrai comme louis
aubert et le brillant le brillant et
grands
tu as cassé l'ambiance thierry
c'est la queue de boeuf quelque chose
c'est maintenant c'est super je suis ce
que c'est bon ça te plairait beaucoup
moi tu me plais beaucoup aussi
le fait
la question n'est pas là je comprends
très bien que la chaîne 7 que vous les
plaisirs sont appelés à 10 son jeu plaît
à de son nom mais le problème les pièces
qui veut
ma mort c'est la chaîne non moyens
si tu es marié genève un compte
chez mec toile a presque eu forcément
branché or dix ans a redit ce ne sera
pas le cuir à
juliette
vous n'avez pas compris où se cachait le
drame parce qu'il volait que vous
puissiez répondre
ardisson vous plaît
jacques se casse la baraque son seul
nom mais c'est pour ça que c'est pesé
mais c'est pour ça qu'il a posé la
question rien à voir la queue de boeuf
est indécent de
la communauté sur le mirage bon moi je
vais pisser excusez moi ça m'a excité
tout ça
au stade
est moins bonne qu'une autre c'est
comment ça va mais je suis en train de
dîner avec jacques chancel vahina
giocante tu la connais elle est énorme
attente il faut que je te la présenta tu
vas mourir est trop belle si jamel elle
est trop belle
ah ouais elle est trop belle elle est l
écorce elle est elle allée la zone 2 les
mariages manyanga simplement je dois
rencontrer voilà avec 4 0 un pianiste
qui sans doute un bon pianiste collard
mais qu'est ce que tu veux que se disent
les mecs qui ne fait pas les beavers
moi j'ai suivi avec bernard si tu ne les
y
est
c'est jamel debbouze ces impayés à toi
temps je te le pass
1 jour
comment vois tu vas bien alors
oui on s'est régalé tu te rappelles
il serait ça va tout va bien tant forme
tenté ou la scène rakesh août à paris
ouais c'est quand un projet
le veinard et paroisse êtres
était le plus heureux du monde perrin
président allait rappeler au brésil où
la donne j'en avais dit moi je fais des
loges cette enveloppe sera l'offre de
l'année prochaine lui qui n'a eu pour
moi jusqu'à saint jacques chancel il
faut que ça me donne hélas comme tu dis
que dieu te protège
tic tac tic tac tic tac
attaque a quitté ton quartier tactique
et petit à petit à telenet tecteo 4
octobre et confrontés et par autoroute
on t'attend tu attaques et contre
attaques ont coûté 4 écrit pour conter
et quittait au quartier de ngadi
d'actualité takashi d'activité taghavi
tacle était tout à côté des quatre
thématiques qui n'était au caire pour
coca et d'éthique conquête tout autre
écho tonkin côté des disputes et excité
d'être de ton qui comptait tourner quand
tout un tas de tickets de caisse dans
tout un coup tic-tac tic-tac ni
on m'appelle qu'un réveil matin
tu as écrit l'ours blanc de peau pour
une sonnerie c'est une belle sonneries
et voilà
au
pays
on paye
trop tendre des cas c'est un
c'est pourquoi
marchand de pour pas la portée par jean
amoureux c'est pas
j'ai un parent ni au monde m pour les
oiseaux mais les sonos hbgary temps
qu'il aurait serré crotta de ce combo
revenant jeunes dans un avion
au vélo prague où il y avait une fille
qui forme de déclasser fanni 6 touches
pour mieux verser aux pays d'où le
casting vient fêter le gars au diplôme
donné glace vanille citron j'aime mieux
les gâteaux au chocolat programmé chef
pâtissier il n'y en a plus c'est bon tu
sais pourquoi je n'ai appris troupes et
pour les défilés je mangeais pourtour
des celle du camembert le camembert ces
vendanges et bien fait pire à ce propos
revenant
c'est parce que je me mélange les
pédales
toi tu t'appelles nourdine en fait non
mais oui monsieur je savais pas c'est
quoi tes kabyle ces nouvelles c'est un
nom arabe pourtant et mon grand-père un
porte un nom arabe était kabyle oui
absolument et puis de plus de vingt
paquets de génération ils ont grand
playa fini 1ers gênant il a fini oui ou
non il est une carrière assez
intéressant parce qu'en fait il est
parti d'algérie en fait il a il est
parti de son bled il a il était assez
jeune il avait le certif d'études dans
la poche puis après il a trouvé un job
chez un avocat à alger où il a fait un
peu grouillot quoi et la légende de
familiale veut qu'il est débrouillé une
affaire pour cet avocat qu'il avait
repéré des trucs et que l'avocat
cherchaient désespérément la solution et
et le grand père qui était malin il
avait trouvé la solution en le papier
qui traînait au fin fond d'un tiroir et
l'avocat en question lui elle a donc
pris sous son aile a fait un peu
pygmalion et l'a envoyé en france pour
faire des études
mon grand-père et est arrivé en france
en dans les années 20 environ 1,27 je
crois un truc comme ça et puis il a
commencé par l'avs et des tramways à
marseille pour gagner sa croûte mais en
même temps il avait quand même un
soutien financier il a pu faire des
études et il a fait sciences po droit
etc il rentre à la police alors il est
rentré au bas de l'échelon inspecteurs
quand même et puis là gravier
commissaire commissaire divisionnaire et
il a fini directeur des rg ouais
tout le reste de ma famille est
absolument
français pur ce pur sucre
avec le grand père mais il a laissé le
nom est un beau nom en plus nourris
tenez moi ça veut dire un truc non ça
veut dire lumière de la foi
ah ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
oui ça c'est moi
oh
à
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
aller danser un primate géant les lycées
vraiment déçu un peu
encore encore une fois parce que la
ballerine arrive
[Musique]
e
suite
aulas
bon
[Musique]
on
non
[Musique]
où
oh
l'abonné
[Musique]
choisi un chiffre entre 1 et 9
mai tu multiplies ce chiffre par neuf oh
[__]
tu additionne les deux chiffres de ce
nombre
il sort alors là tu obtiens nouveaux
chiffres tu enlèves 5 à ce chiffre
ça y est on le sait à chaque lui à
chacune un chiffre correspond une lettre
par exemple le un ca le 2 cb le 3 c'est
la vie c'est le cas de céder le 500e le
6 f alors trouves tu dois trouver un
pays qui commence par cette lettre
prêt et tu dois me donner un fruit qui
commence par la dernière lettre de ce
pays un fruit qui commence par la
dernière lettre de ce trio oui nous le
dit 'pour pêche
de répondre quand même que tu es un peu
demeuré parce que tu crois qu'ils aient
des kiwis au danemark fort c'est ma
forme et on joue comme on va se dire
elle ouais
y'a un con il ya déjà un gros pied j'ai
une roulette la maladie c'est lui il ya
un copier une roulette qui voilà après
ce que j'espère moi j'y connais rien
mais vous savez les bons soins oui
bonsoir monsieur je suis le croupier
pour votre soirée casino à domicile
quatrième étage merci
non c'est toi qui dois avoir la banque
est ce que tu es armée parce que nous on
est capable de la faire sauter vous
rejoindre haïti réponse est plus
jolie des vrais pognon tirait ouais
ouais bien sûr si on gagne l'accord 35
fois la mise
acheter les parts à
d'ailleurs y ait une réelle une règle en
3d jamais là
la région ne savais pas que tu joues
émotions m'avait dit que l'agent du
service public passé dans les passes et
dans les tripots mais je vois tu vois
c'est la perversion du bonhomme tout de
suite l'argent du serveur mais ça veut
rien dire
mais qu'est ce que tu fais avec toi avec
ton argent dollar
en plus ce produit je n'ai jamais été
par
le couple au piémont soir
je suis le croupier de la soirée casino
qui va se passer aux voiries sont pas là
ce soir
donc voilà une table de roulette sera à
votre disposition
chez les mecs ils m'ont alors il n'y a
pas de maximum
ceux qui sont interdits de jeu ici
laquelle maximale du jeu du numéro plein
par exemple
on va essayer de déterminer mais sachant
qu'on va jouer avec des jetons de 1000
dollars d'accords
jouer mille dollars dom est un maximum
de 100 millions $ sur le plein cent
mille dollars ans c'est pas mal
alors je vais déjà vous expliquer les
règles donc si vous jouez un numéro
plein là je joue par exemple 11,6 ce
numéro sort je gagne 35 fois la mise
un numéro joué 35 fois la mise je peux
jouer maintenant à cheval ici je joue le
cheval 5,8 viscères siens de ses deux
numéros sort comme le monsieur s'est dit
cette fois la mise je peux jouer
maintenant
une transversale ici qui me permet de
jouer trois numéros 7 8 et 9 de ce côté
là où de ce côté là on se fait la mise
pour les trois numéros je peux jouer un
quart est ici je joue le bien mais 11 15
qui englobe le 11 le 12 le 14 et le 15
si un de ces quatre numéros sort je
gagne 8 fois la mise je peux jouer
dernières possibilités 1 6 ans ici je
joue si numéro 10 11 12 13 14 15
sainte-cécile numéro sort je gagne 5
fois la mise
tu connais par coeur ah non alors ici
vous voyez des cases vides
alors je peux jouer dedans que ça me
permet de jouer toute cette colonne
c'est médiocre
non ce qu'il faut c'est pas tout perdu
alors de faire la bise à savoir combien
ça va quand même alors un show rouge un
sens une plaque bleue vaut mieux aller
d'accord alors pendant pendant la soirée
je vais vous poser des question quiz
sont en rapport avec le cabinet de
questions de casino qui lui permettront
de remporter au noir mille francs de
plus
à la fin de la partie des gens très cher
et là je vous offre un super cadeau
celui qui aura gagné finalement le plus
d'argent pourra repartir avec un très
très beau van as voyages
alors à vos jeux mesdames messieurs
faites vos jeux
ça va chier car moi je suis aux rasses
lourds aux
rapaces s'ajoutent 21
banny mahina joue le 7 et le 4 donc
c'est 17 fois la mise et pas 35 vous
allez retenue vous de la messieurs les
jeux sont faits
les jeux sont faits mesdames messieurs
les jeux sont marqués 0 2
elle m'a plu c'est le 23 23
tout est à moi je ne crois pas
moi j'ai des douleurs et les chevaux
c'est en vidéo 09 23 tant de chance elle
a pris combien une fortune chancelle il
a assuré grâce érotisme des couleurs
sans doute mais
tu as compris à cette fois ci car tout
ce qu'il a pris soin c'est pas énorme
c'est énorme alors effrayée que j'allais
pas de 6,5 et 6,7 c'est vrai ça le grand
lyon avec les compliments du personnel
monsieur et qu'il attend voici monsieur
2 3 4 alors d'accord premier cheval il
est tout entouré le 23 avec pourquoi le
23 alors j'ai attaqué ce que je joue
tous les chevaliers de l'e3 une se
valent en permanence il 7 g annonce
qu'il a pris cette même c'est riche et
yahoo en quarts et je vous plais 800
avec les compliments du personnel madame
voici et puis à sait moins c'est que ces
petits péré escamps mais à toi ces 8e
bah moi j'ai une quatre ans ce mois-ci
alors 1100 abba corps même si question
conversion personne merci monsieur pour
le personnel
monsieur monsieur est un seigneur
les jeux sont faits mais là messieurs
les oeufs son frère et moi je disais les
oeufs sont frais c'est que je vais faire
un oeuf ouais
rien ne va plus pour le 35 e ri ya du
monde sur le 35
il va ivanov
le tuyau le trio jacques martin garneau
parce que mon jeu je vous dis c 09 23 35
je viens de sortir le 23 le 35
normalement le neuf le 9 et 17 0 allez
hop et près du 23 il ya le dis parce que
c'est un grand professionnel
[Applaudissements]
petite question quiz attention à 2000
ouais je veux gagner 2000 j'ai rien
toucher tout a
dit m qui à réglementer les jeux en
france napoléon bonaparte voilà
et ça je le mets sur le 12 quand j'ai
tout mis sur le 12
j'espère que je vais y arriver parce que
je n'ai plus rien je veux avoir un peu
de monnaie monsieur
2000 au change en 2000 n'est survenu les
jeux sont faits beaulieu
arrêté moussoulens surface faire place
il faut jouer au dernier moment très
triste
c'est le 5 5
joël st louis
alors le cheval c'est vos valises à 700
me voici avec les compliments du
personnel madame eu pas moins que le
profil des messages personnels il ya
normalement qui
échangent tiens tu veux mettre ça sur le
7e plaît voilà merci
le set
alors là je vais faire un
super coup de jarnac vrai mais je le
décide pas tout de suite parce que
je ne veux pas je ne veux pas qu'ils
croient que je me dégonfle s'entraider
bien vingt six personnes
on va attendre alors les jeux sont faits
[Applaudissements]
aïe aïe aïe énervant cela fait
sur 7 merci jésus
jésus sur la croix
c'est jésus merci jésus toi et tous les
cas tout à jésus
jésus musée on se dirige avec moi mais
il faudra gagner des yeux rivés
j'ai joué le jeu c'était que je jouais
seul voilà si j'ai joué un chiffre tout
cela bien sûr tu m'as fait à cheval
match mais ça a payé nos billets gens
priaient et sa
mère si jésus
jésus
je sais
jamais
[Musique]
qui gagne c'est jacques il flotte russe
bien qu'à regarde regarde on se dit
c'est pas possible à des méthodes agiles
martingale ouais mais ça fonctionne il
bafouille alors ta martingale ces 09 23
35 des fois ça marche pas car j'ai pas
fait mieux cette m'attendre
et je suis faire attendez attendez je
n'ai pas joué un sacré ga qu'un seigneur
lors de nos mains n'allez pas ce qu'ils
veulent dans une joute à lui il en met
un peu partout et non pas par tous et le
petit épargnant rien we found love him
et du cheval farmer
moi j'ai joué 7 et 11 0 et jeux sont
faits je sens fait attention cette et en
santé oms étudiants déloger tous et les
rentes référence oh là là où tombent les
91 hague
a appelé
c'est le vin
saint jacques et saint amand parti je
reconnais que son plan financier jacques
azam est un parti que moi je suis
d'accord tu as toujours sur l'a7 mal cet
élan je suis bon je sais que c'est
comme ça
qu'on fait
attention à moi petit cheval
cette hausse constatée en satin ou sajoo
c'est pay s est payé comme on est payé
tout le monde est payé faites vos jeux
bon attendez moi je vous propose quelque
chose et on est obligé
du mat organise des soirées comme ça un
peu partout dans paris ah ouais ouais
effectivement j'organise des soirées
dans l'est dans les boîtes échangistes
arrive de temps en temps votre chambre
les chandelles
no coment tu connais nos comme je pense
à toi il est vachement est donc là bon
les règles sont un peu différentes il
faut que les gens quand ils perdent ils
enlèvent un vêtement j'imagine non il ya
d'autres gages il dégage plus dur est
fait le mec par exemple il obligé tu as
perdu tu t'es obligé de donner par
exemple madame madame vous avez perdu
donc vous serez jésus attaché 1 et puis
madame vous serez donc l'esclave
sexuelle de monsieur pendant deux tours
qu'est ce qui se passe
je regardais tombé sur le 33 c'est le
cylindre à côté du 33 il ya le veut quoi
comme numéro 1 l'un est le combien et le
16 bon tu joues le un réel 16 pour
protéger tu fais est réellement voisins
et puis tu fais c'est un voisin donc ça
peut être intéressant moi et là je
laisse car le 16 et on sent que c'est un
vrai joueur de crédit de cette es11 je
sentais le 11 mai là par exemple je peux
m'amuser aussi avec le 21 c'est un
compliment alors vous connaissez le
proverbe qui dit qu'ils persévèrent n'y
voit plus rien as tu veux dire tu penses
que moi je suis content de faire c'est à
dire que vous obstinez sur sur deux
numéros tu penses que c'est canal je ne
sais pas ça peut sortir mais ça peut
très bien ne pas sortir pendant 20 ans -
t'as vu ma base elle est sortie n'y a
que le zéro qui n'est pas encore sorti
mais là je vais le prouver allons-y ah
oui tu as raison ce 0 0 il a joué les
héros à 27 euros et 0
la zero moss
tout le monde choisit du monde 0
rien ne va plus
[Applaudissements]
pour sourcer magie il n'y a pas de quoi
payer
j'ai sorti la pompe unis regardent la
caisse j'espère qu'on va de zéro
monsieur chancellerie après ça il va
chanter les quatre numéros + avait
annoncé j'ai un calme alors là ça fait
un sacré g0 gésir options dont je n'ai
double accord mais n'a pu ainsi ce qui
se passe là qu'est ce qui se passe je
peux plus vous payez d'autres comme un
maître un drap noir sur le sur la table
on l'a on a ainsi fini la bande des
terrasses et qui a gagné le voyage alors
avec vahina alors monsieur il a il a
gagné un voyage il a gagné un voyage
donc je lui offre donc un voyage aller
retour pour rome
donc on peut l'applaudir bien fort
alors attention
gg les billets dans la poche très bien
sur leur sort donc deux tickets en métro
pour la station robe
de monsieur mozart
la tartine de beurre à
[Musique]
en
c'est vrai que c'est inouï vous avez une
chance phénoménale oui mais ça c'est que
ça peut arriver une fois par hasard
parce que là on pourrait être tenté de
braquer si
on pourrait être tenté de croire qu'ils
aient une astuce alors que là on est
tous c'est ce que vous auriez jouer de
la même manière dans un vrai casino si
j'avais pris le 23 et 35 au départ oui
autrement nous d'accord oui skate snow
c'est lorsque nous avons tous j'ai joué
les héros j'ai tout le monde a dit moss
et tu joues 0 dure encore gagné mais ça
le zéro mais ça a été tout le monde a
joué 0-0 et sentez
les alizés mais quand même des mystères
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu